we have a fellow who uh criticized my
notion
of the scientific method can you believe
that criticizing the scientific the real
scientific method okay
and uh so
give me a second here let me remove
this okay and so he's a what i call a
science critic okay and uh what he's
going to complain about is he says
that you you
you can understand physics right physics
or physical mechanisms or whatever you
can understand them but you don't have
to be able to visualize them
in other words he doesn't relate
understanding with visualization okay
and i think more or less the opposite
i'm saying that in physics
physics is about mechanisms
and if you cannot visualize it if you
cannot
make a movie
of your mechanism
you did not understand it okay so that's
going to be the issue let me put him on
so that you can hear from the horse's
mouth okay give me a second here and
here goes listen carefully
the issue to be addressed in this
rebuttal is
if you cannot visualize a mechanism
have you understood it
so it's not really about visualizing it
it's about understanding it yes
visualizing it can help but it's not the
be-all end-all if you can't visualize
something but you can understand it then
that's more important than being able to
visualize it but not being able to
understand it
okay we got it
that's the issue
before him today you know the subject
matter today and let's uh start with
what science is and what science is not
because that's i think where the problem
starts we have to go all the way down to
science and find out what is science
about yeah i think that's where the
issue is okay so here we go um
science according to this site our
channel right um
is about explaining rationally and only
about explaining rationally what is the
definition we have
rational explanations very simple very
straightforward not worthy
very concise
very
difficult to challenge because it's
concise
on the other hand what you have today uh
you know uh is this notion that people
have that of what science is or in their
minds okay what they think science is
they think it's about observing studying
uh running experiments making
predictions i forgot to put in there you
know i just this just came out of the
top of my head uh you know the fact that
they use math and equations okay that's
got nothing to do with science either we
don't do why because math is about
describing math can only describe an
equation can only describe so that's not
part of science we explain we do not
describe anyone can describe a chair
okay not everyone can explain you know
how gravity works okay so that's where
you have to break your brains okay
voting for theories we do not have
democracy
in science we do not also have tradition
we don't say well that's why we always
did it you know if it don't work
meaning in science explanation you
cannot explain then we have to change it
we have to do something about it it's
broken we have to fix what is broken
okay and we don't do winning prizes none
of that stuff okay so what is instead
science okay well there you have it and
uh here you have uh the mathematical
method mathematical method as we call it
this is what we inherited from the
people in the 17th so-called uh
centuries so-called scientific
revolution it's a which is really a
method of research and persuasion what
they did is include things on
how to do experiments in your little
dark basement you do research you do
study you put your brains to work no
problem there but then you know when you
have to come to the
conference what you have to do is
explain what you learned instead they
emphasize and harp on um persuasion they
said let me convince you let me show you
proof let me show you evidence no no
that's not science okay and so they have
all these uh
steps in the so-called mathematical
method here you know
observe explain tentatively which they
call a hypothesis they do predictions
they do experiments they describe
mathematically you know and they call it
a theory which is not a theory theory is
an explanation not a description an
equation is not an explanation okay they
invent technology they think that they
with that they confirm the theory they
convince
other mathematicians they talk about
truth fact you know knowledge you know
we know you don't know we know okay and
we proved it through some experiment
okay
and then they uh verify through
measurement in other words someone else
uh tries to verify your measurement
especially your description your
mathematical description and if they
confirm it uh well then they uh we're
not able to falsify it there's no
falsification of your theory and as long
as it's not falsified oh that means that
you can continue rolling and believe it
it's about belief then they win prizes
and they do the celebrity circuit that's
the that's essentially the method today
that they have out there and now we're
saying that's not that's not science
sciences rational explanations
specifically it's as it's related to
physics which is what we do here okay so
what is physics well here we have it
this is a gives you an idea what physics
is okay
uh well first uh
we have it here um those who have a
different version of this scientific
method the one that we propose rational
explanations well they have a single
recourse okay and that is uh to propose
a definition that they can defend
okay
and uh so uh they should be able to use
it consistently and then
if it's worth anything their scientific
method or their version of science they
should be able to explain how the
universe works the things we are
interested in explaining we want to know
how gravity works we want to know how
magnetism works
how light works how the atom works this
is what we and by how i don't mean
describe i mean explain the mechanism
what is the cause that's what we're
talking about okay and if you're going
to define if you're going to challenge
the definition rational explanations
right if you're going to challenge that
definition well uh
you know the more things that you add to
your definition you're making you know a
big paragraph 200 words 500 words right
the more words you put in there the
easier it will be to destroy your notion
of science okay because you will not be
able to apply it consistently the more
predicates you include in there okay so
uh that's something you got to keep in
mind if you're going to challenge the
definition and here is um
uh you know the the person we have today
uh of science it says uh there is
currently no consensus regarding the
definition of life this is an example of
why you know you you can't put too many
predicates in there because it's easier
to tear down and i'm giving you an
example here in the word life okay
nobody has been able to define the world
life in other words no biologist on
planet earth has any clue how to define
the word life okay they never define the
word but they're all biologists which is
the study of life according to them okay
and so you have one popular definition
this comes from the wikipedia is that
organisms are open systems that what
that maintains homeostasis
are composed of cells have a life cycle
undergo metabolism can grow adapt to
their environment respond to stimuli
reproduce evolve etc okay great okay so
it says there for example uh um
let's see let me pick one out of here
uh reproduce for example well my
grandmother doesn't reproduce uh anymore
uh my aunt never reproduce were they
alive
okay uh can grow what if you don't grow
anymore what if you shrink uh does that
mean that you're you're not alive
so you can see how easy it is to tear
this definition down because they put so
many predicates and so many conditions
for defining the word life and that's
the problem when you define the word um
science the more words you put in there
the tougher it's going to be for you to
defend that definition because you're
going to have to be able to apply each
one of those predicates
each one of those conditions each one of
those specifications
to whatever challenge you receive
okay so that's why you know all my
definitions are
very short
it makes it hard for someone to attack
it and it's got to contain the essence
in fact all definitions should be that
form the foundations of science of
physics of philosophy have to be very
very short as short as you can make them
get rid of words the more words you put
in there the easier it's going to be to
tear down okay that's my rule of thumb
for you okay take it or leave it okay
and here we have the word physics okay
which we want to define this is what we
do here okay
uh science is divided into two
categories and one of those and only two
categories okay one is physics and the
other one's philosophy okay we're gonna
do a little bit with philosophy today
because we have this uh issue of um the
multi-universe of the universe
and so what is physics physics the
branch of science that attempts to
explain mechanisms rationally
rational explanations of
what of mechanisms that's physics
and uh philosophy is rational
explanations of behaviors in comparison
okay
and specifically gravitational
electromagnetic phenomena that's what we
want to explain that's what remains out
there we we've been able to explain
everything we can see and touch
that we're more or less familiar with we
have not been able to explain in the
last three thousand years that which we
cannot see that which we cannot touch
that's where the problem is they have
not been able to answer that and what
they do is do a lot of math and then
they give you an irrational explanation
and then they say well that's not
important anyways that's just philosophy
opinion and that's what they call
science that they gave you a descript a
mathematical description in lieu of an
explanation okay and so again the more
predicates you introduce
the worse it's going to be for you if
you're going to define the word physics
okay so we say rational explanations of
mechanisms that's very short how do they
define it i think i have it here uh this
is the definition of from the wikipedia
okay
physics is the natural sciences studies
matter it's fundamental constituents
it's motion and behavior through space
and time and the related entities of
energy and force okay so you can see a
quite lengthy definition or notion that
they have today and what's the problem
with it well energy emotion and force
are concepts uh physics does not study
concepts that's probably where it all
falls apart but um it talks about the
you know actually they're referring to
uh descriptions but they say it's
studies no physics doesn't study
anything you could be studying anything
you want okay and that doesn't mean
you're gonna learn that doesn't mean you
know you understand something okay so
studying is not enough even children
study does is a child who studies in
kindergarten is he or she is a scientist
because he studies
so studies alone does not do the trick
you can study all you want when you come
to the conference we want you to explain
what you understood what you learned you
know share with us your intelligence but
if you just say i studied and then you
got a zero on the test what was the
point of studying i mean prove that you
studied and the way you prove it is by
explaining
so no to say that you studied and it
says studies matter okay so you studied
matter what did you learn fundamental
constituents okay what are the
fundamental constituents space-time is
that a fundamental constituent energy
mass force time are those fundamental
constituents of you know the universe
and then it says it's motion yeah we do
uh try to explain motion but motion of
things that we can see is no problem the
question is motion of that which we
cannot see and touch okay that's where
it falls apart again okay and again
behavior through space and time again we
don't go through space or time because
neither time or space are physical
mechanisms they're not containers
they're not media okay so you cannot say
that you go through space or you go
through time okay so whatever through
uh means in there in this
context here now we don't we don't go
through space or through time you can't
say you go through space or through time
not in physics maybe in some kind of
religion out there mathematics you know
then you can talk about going through
space and time
okay so um
um
you know here here we have a case for
this gentleman who says
that
a mechanism you do not have to visualize
it you can just understand it
and we can say no you you if you cannot
visualize it you did not understand the
mechanism
and as poor fellow he doesn't understand
that okay so here we go let's give give
him an example i'm going to show you
something that happened okay it's going
to be uh window breaks
very simple stuff okay and i'm going to
show you that first okay here it goes we
have something going through the window
it's known as a horseshoe and here we
have a little felix the candy revolves
it shows this horseshoe okay so you can
see how it broke okay so if you ask
anybody okay what did you just see there
and they would say how did the window
break how did the uh
glass end up on the floor well i think
everybody would say the same thing say
well there was a horseshoe thrown and
hit the window and broke it very simple
okay okay now what if we do it this way
okay here we have it
and um
and this guy just waves his arm
did you see what broke it can you tell
me exactly how the window broke now now
that you cannot see the mediators okay
all you see is a guy waving his arm okay
and then the window suddenly breaks like
by magic remote control
so how do the mathematicians do it well
they say they give you a description
they say something like this okay they
say that you get this force that goes
through the window okay they use all
these mathematical concepts so they say
look he waved the mass
okay and with all this energy right and
the force went through the window that's
the kind of answer you get from a
mathematician well so far you you have
no ex no physical interpretation for how
the window broke you cannot use these
words to explain how the window broke
the way you say it is you say a horse
you went through the window okay and we
do not need to know the resistance of
the glass none of that nonsense that
people get into we just need to know how
the window broke and it's very simple
the mechanism is horseshoe went through
window period tarzan like that's how you
explain that and you do not use these
words just mass energy or force okay
let me give you another example okay
just so we know that you have to explain
if you're going to explain a mechanism
you have to put objects in front of the
eyes so you should be able to illustrate
it the language of physics is not
mathematics
mathematics you know energy mass force
all that time you know that nonsense the
language of physics is illustration you
should have objects in front of my eyes
so that i can see the mechanism and just
by watching the entire show there i can
get an idea of how the window broke or
whatever whatever mechanism you're
trying to explain okay that's the point
so you should be able to illustrate you
should be able to visualize the
mechanism in order to say that you
understood it otherwise you can't say
well i can't visualize it but i
understood it
now you're lying
you're you're kidding or you're fooling
yourself you thought you understood it
you can't visualize it the mechanism you
have not understood it in physic you
need to visualize okay so here's another
example okay and here we have it we have
a pulley okay and it's pulling on a box
very simple stuff okay so you ask how
did the box go up very simple stuff okay
and you say okay someone pulled on the
rope and i was wound around the pulley
and that's what and which was also tied
to the box and you know that's how the
box went up we can all explain how the
box went up because it's all connected
okay now let's do it uh the invisible
way okay suddenly the box goes up
okay and you say well how did the box go
up was it magic
i mean you know now we don't see the
mediator which in this case was the rope
right and suddenly the box goes up and
it's very scary because you cannot
explain it why because you cannot see or
touch whatever is pulling the box up
how do the mathematicians do it well
this is the way they do it over there
they say well there's this mass and
there's a force that's maybe pushing it
from below because they don't see
anything there and say there's so much
energy involved okay
and uh it went up in so much time okay
so far we haven't answered the question
what is the physical mechanism and so
you say well you know i cannot visualize
it i cannot make a movie of it all i can
do is uh describe it with all these
mathematical terms there's so much force
and they give you a number followed by a
unit there's so much mass number
followed by a unit so much energy number
followed by unit so much time numbers
followed by a unit that's what they give
you and they say well yeah yeah there's
a force pushing up the mass with so much
energy and it took so much time that's
the kind of answer you get and you say
what's the mechanism how did the box go
up what what caused the box to go up and
they have no answer for that okay and uh
so yeah so the question is what's the
mechanism and so they say well maybe it
was worth space the worst base pulls it
down or warped time you know usually
it's warped time okay they pulled it
down and so the box is pulling against
it and you still don't know what's
putting it against the warp space yeah
why is what's causing the box to go
against warp space you still have no
mechanism for what's pulling the box up
and so yeah unless you can illustrate
the mechanism okay you you have not
understood it all you can do is describe
it and say uh uh mathematically in this
case you say there's so much energy so
much force so much mass so much time or
whatever other parameter you want to put
in there but you have not been able to
explain it so this fellow says that yeah
you know you can you can um understand
it uh but not be able to visualize the
mechanism and the answer is
no
if you cannot make a movie of your
theory of your mechanism in physics you
have not understood it you have to put
physical objects in physics physics
first and foremost is
you need an object you can't do physics
without an algae you need something
there for that you need to find the word
object